with 20 hours of focused effort most
people can be pretty decent at something
whether it's guitar it's singing even
cold calling but most people spend years
waiting to do the first hour how can I
decrease that action threshold and get
someone to just embrace the suck it's
like how can I normalize no's so it's
like if I'm teaching somebody to sell
it's like dude I need to get 100 of
those if the no becomes the goal then
they realize that it's about the
processing or the outcome and then they
will become better sales people because
they stop being afraid of it we do like
exposure therapy on things that people
are most afraid of the same thing like
for training salesperson I want them to
hear the gas everyone's afraid of saying
the price it's like dude if you didn't
get a gasp you didn't go high enough
right they're like what I'm like oh you
failed terrible sale they didn't gasp
like really it flips it and becomes a
point of Pride it's like oh I got it you
could hear the gasp on this one and so